am i saying
that results are not important oh no i
get it i'm a capitalist i totally get it
but results are half the leader's job
and the other half is that respect piece
and if there's not equal
time commitment attention
paid to making po people feel like
they're
they belong like like they're important
like we can't do this without you
then then the whole business
relationship changes
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel and an immediate
partnership with ctek
let's talk about good and good comes
first to meet chris edmonds president
ceo and founder of the purposeful
culture group and co-author of good
comes first
for decades talented people have
tolerated old school leaders who put
results before respect toxic company
cultures and workplaces that suck
but those days are over and if leaders
want to attract and retain the best
employees while improving productivity
customer service employee satisfaction
and profits it's time for them to create
work cultures where good comes first the
problem is that because the corporate
world has too often been driven
primarily by results we seldom ask
leaders to change their work cultures
even if we did most leaders don't have
know-how
this book provides the actionable
inspiration and practical direction
needed to make that changes happen
and good comes first chris and his
co-author mark babbitt presents proven
strategies that help senior leaders
define align and refine the purposeful
positive and productive work cultures
cultures where good comes first for
employees customers leaders and
stakeholders and where improved business
outcomes quickly follow
crest edmonds welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
how are you
i'm doing very well michael thank you
for the opportunity no this is so
exciting because we're going to talk
about something that i've been you know
thinking about constantly and you know i
think that a lot of people from my
generation are talking about it a lot
i'm seeing a lot of my friends as
engineers as they're going into
companies thinking about you know
culture and what's happening i'm looking
at a lot of the early stage founders i
work with and what they're looking at
and and we're going to talk about what's
written on your shirt good comes first
tell me what what does that even mean
that is the title of my upcoming book
with my colleague mark babbitt the book
has been in the works for five years
we've been writing it for three
it releases on
tuesday the 28th of september so and
venus williams rode the forward one of
my one of my childhood idols until today
and and still like he wrote a day that's
a cool story but yeah she uh reached out
to me about
three years ago and said i've got these
two small companies and i think
our culture can use some improvement so
i've been working with them for
shoot about about year and a half two
years now
incredible incredible okay chris three
years of writing five years in the works
what what does good comes first mean
what does that mean
you know what what the foundational idea
is simple to say given all the
interesting norms in organizations and
we'll talk about that in a bit
some of the interesting ways that
leaders manage businesses it doesn't
create an environment where employees
associates team members
are
honored
validated and treated with respect it
just is not common in fact we have
typically the opposite that is much much
more common and so the book is about
helping leaders actually take change
steps that we promise work if you follow
through right because most change
efforts kind of they start with a bang
and then pretty quickly they they fizzle
out because it's hard work to do
but the idea around good comes first is
that if your employees are treated
well respect validation they will
increase problem solving they will be
much much happier they will work more
cooperatively together they will wow
your customers in really good ways
and not surprisingly and we've got the
proof
results go up profits go up if that's
one of your things
so i mean it sounds intuitive happy
workers happy company
when went all around why is it so hard
why do people come to you and say chris
we need help yep what's what's very
interesting
is to have
a perspective
i've got a lot of birthdays under my
belt and i've had some really great
bosses and some really awful bosses
and i started to look and this was 50
years ago so
when i really got into the workforce
after after school and realized
okay i
i i've seen
some patterns here so what are the
patterns of good bosses duh what are the
patterns of lousy bosses
and the issue why are
why gallup's wonderful engagement data
has remained for 30 years at about 30 33
we might peak at 35 that means 60 plus
percent of the population is not engaged
is not happy
and so
our foundational principle is you've got
to make values as important as results
you must make respect on equal par as
performance and profits
and and the reason why that hasn't been
the case is many of us have had leaders
who are still deeply immersed in
industrial age thinking i'm the boss
you'll do what i tell you to do
you know no you can't have flexible
hours no you can't go out and work out
during the launch hour right it is a
very commanding control kind of mindset
and and what has been very interesting
for me in the last
been doing this about 30 years but the
last 10 years as younger generations
begin to get plugged into
formal leadership responsibilities the
reason why those folks get plugged into
a role is because they sound like their
boss they behave like their boss they
make the same decisions and the same
they fear the same things
and so in essence we've got this
we've got this virus that's a terrible
thing to say today i know
we call it bms boomer male syndrome
which is that
and against two old white guys talking
about
the the problems with
too much old school thinking too much
command-and-control thinking if you've
got boomer male syndrome you may be
inhibiting people bringing their best
selves to work
having fun at work doing the creative
problem solving so
the norms that are still embedded when
did we get into the social age i think i
did my first website in 1995. we are
still holding on to
those classic command and control norms
from from leaders and and those aren't
the organizations that gen z's
and gen x's
want to work for that's not where they
want to go that's that's going to
inhibit their creativity and the
flexibility that that many of those
generations
truly appreciate
but it can't be you know trivial or
black and white right i mean every
organization requires a different type
of leadership every type of workplace
every type of job you know some of them
require more micromanagement some of
them require more creativity so how how
can i as a leader team leader ceo
whatever how can i then you know
rationalize through what is the best
form of leadership that i can exert with
my team so that we can reach the best
results
well we go to two different places with
that michael and it's a great question
because we have a tendency as leaders to
kind of stay in our own bubble right do
our thing we're getting feedback from
limited places
and and we may not be able to see the
overall picture which is that do people
feel respected here do they feel valued
here so that's an interesting bias am i
saying
that results are not important oh no i
get it i'm a capitalist i totally get it
but results are half the leader's job
and the other half is that respect piece
and if there's not equal time commitment
attention
paid to making po people feel like
they're
they belong like like they're important
like we can't do this without you
then then the whole business
relationship changes
and
one of the folks that we i was just
thinking about this this morning we're
getting ready to send off books michael
we have books printed
well in advance of launch date which is
really cool but we interviewed robert
passan who is the ceo at radio flyer now
radio flyer is little red wagons been
around for a while since the 20s
but we were so taken by the way that
their
employees on glassdoor because that's a
great way to get data you know what what
are good companies where companies that
then employees feel like they they love
their bosses and you wouldn't believe
the testimonials that these employees
were providing you know a year and a
half ago in the middle of having to shut
down and how do we do this and how do we
team and how do we produce stuff
and and so we were so
taken by the focus that robert had
taking over his grandfather's company
to be able to say
the only way people are going to give
their best in this kind of creative
environment is if they feel trusted if
they feel honored if they feel valued
and he's and his team have built a
remarkable organization so over the
years we've been able to take practices
from best bosses and and let me see if i
can get very tactical because i know we
have 20 minutes we need to get to the
point
one of the ways that we coach leaders to
get their cultures a bit more back in
line a bit more civil maybe even a bit
more respectful is to begin defining
these desirable values like honesty or
integrity
in tactical terms so as you say some
jobs need micromanagement well every job
needs micromanagement of respectful
treatment and it means
that we need to help you
define values and observable terms so if
you go out into one of your one of the
companies that you work with and invite
people to define integrity classic value
how many answers are you going to get
you might get 10 you might get 30
because well in this case it does this
but in that
we need to decide exactly what our
integrity value
looks like
so and as you can imagine many clients
that come to us they say we want to have
an integrity value okay let's talk about
what that looks like what are people
doing consistently that you can see that
you can hear that you can watch and so
one of the very common behaviors we
coach leaders to use around integrity is
i do what i say i will do
now we've shifted from this vague
relationships but results results
results to
i keep my promises if i make a promise i
follow up on it
then that
let's call it a desirable characteristic
gets rated twice a year by that person's
direct reports now we're moving from an
exclusive
let's call it pipeline of performance
data that gets evaluated day in and day
out and analyzed and scrutinized and
people unhappy to say you can't work
here unless you treat people with
respect with integrity and this is what
we mean by that and we're going to
measure it
and as you can see what that does is it
gives leaders
firm ground to build
an uncompromising culture upon instead
of hoping people all know what i mean by
respect or what i mean by excellence
that makes a lot of sense but how can i
as a leader
know that i even have a problem right i
mean one of the big issues that that i
know leaders are facing is that you know
those surveys that are being sent out to
employees you know that we don't
necessarily get get all the right
information there and how and i as a
leader i'm so subjective to what i know
already and what my own people are
already telling me how can i actually
know whether you know there's poop where
i'm where i'm at right i mean that's the
bottom line where we want to get to
well we we talk about truth tellers for
all leaders having people that you can
trust who will call you on your crap is
a really good thing yeah and we need and
we need a pretty good sized tribe of
truth-tellers because everyone's going
to have a different viewpoint of a
different facet of the business and a
different facet of the norms right and
the operational kinds of biases that we
have that we may not see but you're
right
employee surveys don't often get
followed up on they often
too often don't get shared
so we're big believers in the in the
survey thing and kind of the the
constant fingers on the pulse and so we
coach leaders to number one if you're
seeing
performance issues if you're seeing
frustration issues and of course here we
are in the middle of post-pandemic or
maybe not right is there a hybrid
workplace is it remote are kids going to
be able to go to school we're still
from a social standpoint
there's it's not just the workplace that
gets our attention anymore there's a lot
of stuff going on and a lot of it isn't
fun
and so
leaders need to be bold to say tell me
how we're doing how am i doing tell me
what drives you nuts
and then
be able to
look at that data and go
oh
well that's good that's good that's good
uh-oh
and then be able to say guys here's what
you told me now now as you can imagine
we just talked about leaders being in a
bubble that bubble gets reinforced every
day and there's no time to think about
morale surveys right
it's like we've got stuff to do and it's
september and it's right
and so
if you are interested in and this is
this is an avenue we really lay heavily
into and it goes back to generational
differences
if you maintain an environment where
leaders are disconnected
they don't care they can be demeaning
and dismissing but they never inquire
then
those younger generations are not going
to tolerate that and they're going to
find organizations where they're a
partner
we talk about co-creating the culture
because everybody's got an experience
let's make it that tribal piece again by
the way that language is from gary
ridge's team at wd-40 company
and and he brought in the tribe stuff 20
years ago and it has really immensely
changed a very important global brand so
leaders have to be able to invite
feedback that may not be pretty
and then realize that you know if my
organization as a whole isn't undergoing
this good comes first effort i can do
with my own team and so we provide some
very tactical simple things like ground
rules right
i remember one team said that that their
most important ground rule was not to
cuss
and it's and everybody laughed and i
said okay so how are you going to hold
each other accountable because that's
the big piece you can invent any rule
but if the rules aren't followed they're
really not helping the culture get
calmer and more fun and more engaging
i think that makes a lot of sense can
you maybe share with me you know an ex a
specific example of where you've worked
with the company and you sort of
expected what happened there and and and
you know came up with there's this issue
but but through through a different
mindset of leadership where good comes
first you're able to achieve some
different results
i do and of course i have ndas with all
my clients so i'll be i'll be a little
bit more broad with this one but this
was a fun one this was a let's talk
about uh a major retailer across the
globe
and we started with this
vp who had three states and over the
course of the partnership that he moved
his his region to seven states and so
we're talking about a lot of stores and
a lot of employees
but their work
actually
and one of the interesting challenges
can be in a multinational multi-state
multi-region you know again the bubble
the bubble gets thicker and you've got
to be able to connect to the entire
organization and they did a great job
they defined their values they had too
many behaviors i coached them that 32
behaviors was too many and they said no
we got this and it worked great
but every morning in their stores
there's a manager-led kind of
team meeting to say here's what's
happening here's what's coming yada yada
they started talking about the valued
behaviors in those meetings at those
stores
and what happened was in
i think the first
engagement survey that was run by
corporate
their region gained 40
compared to the rest of the organization
40 gains in engagement and as you might
guess
there were commensurate gains in
customer service because now all of a
sudden i'm working with an organization
that's saying be nice to people right
this is our job we're trying to help
people get what they need for the day
and and customer service rankings went
up 40
and
in that same time frame their results
improved by 30 now some of those results
weren't all profitability targets that a
lot of other targets but retention
attraction of the right people all of
these things began to and it took about
12 months to get traction
but over the next year next 12 months
they had tremendous tremendous impact
and
this can happen in small companies like
venus williams it can happen in huge
multinationals like world kitchen
and it can happen
more importantly in your team
and and if it happens in your team trust
me that's going to be mostly
your doing you have to kind of change
your mindset a bit and i'll go back to
the classic
if managing results is half your job
don't leave the other half to chance
right let's manage respect as well
amazing i love it now
chris i i'd love to take you back a
little bit you know to your own
childhood your own upbringing you know
before you study this before you go into
this whole world what are you really
what are you really fascinated by what
really sparks your curiosity
one of the pieces that that was
interesting in in my household growing
up my dad was a a mortgage banker
and he actually became the
commissioner of real estate in the state
of california
from 1980 to 1988 so this was a while
back
but he inherited his father's mortgage
company
and and what of course i was offered to
do was to go work at my dad's office yep
so
i was ten right i was eight or nine or
ten
but at some
either it's dna right or my own
experiences i've always been an observer
and it's observing the human condition
yes but i also then immediately judge
what i see which some other humans have
that same tendency right and it could be
and of course as i as i traveled so much
i would go through airports and go
is that how you decided to dress
yourself to fly today and i'm thinking
it constantly right so but what was
interesting going into my dad's
organization was i began seeing
relationships
and it was relationships between bosses
and followers and sometimes the
followers knew everything about what you
know to get done
and they were mostly just frustrated at
their bosses telling them to go do
something that was wrong and i'm like
that's interesting so
i believe that in the other piece of
this and i've got a guitar hanging over
my shoulder i'm a musician on the side
which makes no money whatsoever
but a band is very much a microcosm of
culture
and so if you don't have band members
that are skilled and
civil
oh it gets interesting and i'm now
old enough to say in this band
i'll quit before i put up with another
drama queen of any size gender etc
i love it
it's fascinating and i and i can't wait
to to read the book myself and and and i
think this is so timely and so so
important and amazing and and so i'm
really excited to dive deep into this
myself
what are a few words that you would use
to describe yourself
i am i am definitely
a
a driver to serve others and and because
i've been in the
training development consulting industry
for so long that's really my core drive
is
is we can we can behave independently
and it works for a while or it works for
only a a couple of miles maybe it works
for a decade
but we're we are we are on this planet
with a whole bunch of other folks and
and if we get along
we might be able to make
some changes in
poverty
and understanding across cultural
borders and assumptions i think we've
got a long way to go as a population
here
but if it starts small i mean people
spend what 50 60 hours a week at work
um this is the stuff that drives me and
uh i think i am convinced over the years
that i've changed more people's lives
with the consulting side than the music
side but who knows
chris thank you very very much for your
time i can't wait to read the book thank
you for everything and this is
fascinating and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you
thanks very much for the opportunity
again enjoyed speaking with you of
course thank you
[Music]
you